below the goal line almost impossible
to stop it's a lob little bouncer right
down the middle what a goal what a nice move on
the rookie just great hands in tight it's just
unfair and he goes foring to the right
wing turns his back takes the shot and
SC look how far he changes the angle when he
has it on his back hand demo has to respect
the potential backhand opportunity but then
he changes the angle by about 78 ft then the
perfectly placed shot below the blocker above the
pad almost impossible to stop great play there by
C here's getting it back to Matthews for back to
back kns the hats come flying out on the ice and
this is just another determined play get in on
the floor check win the stick battle it's Marner
who chips it in then no hesitation one foul move
a quick strike pulls it around C's late getting
there and there's the reaction nothing like
starting the season off red hot as he heads
off for a new stick Jack Hugh swooping in sharp
anle haircuts Jack Hugh High stepp it back off
moider below the goal line goalies close your side
door and if you don't the elite players like Jack
Hughes will take advantage of that daylight as
he did there what a play by Jack Hughes was one
of the two red wi goals right up the middle in
on goal for L he scores and there was a penalty
coming up yes but Dylan Len has scored the goal
normally Mo cider is going to drop this puck back
to most likely Dylan Lin cider gets the puck
here it's cleared to the left side and Larin
was shot right down the middle he tucked it went
between the pads but coming to Casey midad pass
across Greenway scores what a goal by Greenway
great job by Jordan Greenway here using his big
frame getting in front of the net dropping his
shoulder Benson he's going to start this one off
he's the one going to feed Casey middle stat the
pass across from middle stat to Greenway was great
middle stat had a Lane right there and he could
have taken the shot but no he finds Greenway right
there Greenway battles through two guys one guy
all over his back the other guy coming in from the
side and he's able to hang on to it come across
the top of the blue Paine and dump it into the
net drop for nander assisted on the power
play go in scor Beauty this is just the end
of a period and a player just taking the game
in his own hands nice job of toar is taking a
body with him she sees the middle taken away
gets it to the outside uses his Edge as well
and gets it around gusterson he realizes he has
some space hands it off to peton back to Garland
and what a beautiful goal the first goal of
the season for the Vancouver canuts off the
Stick of Conor Garland and put a beautiful
move on this bouncing Puck that gets by Bret
kulak it's a lob little bouncer that finds it
right on the stick and quick hands in tight by
Garland goes to the backhand elevates for a
one- nothing lead poke three by Kane and now
McDavid what a spin the recovery the shot he
goes down spin pops back up and somehow that
puck was loose I mean that is absolute nightmare
for that puck to be ahead of him when he gets up
but he attacks with so much speed doesn't
even miss a Beat and then buries it on the
Breakaway wow it's like a whack-a-mole you
thought he was gone and you just popped right
back up I me come on it's just unfair Anderson
on the puck waits to stay outside plays it for
copio Anderson does a nice job of
cutting across the Blue Line holding
on to it Coffield can get into PL slides it
over to him what a nice move on the rookie
cinsky although he doesn't get in across
he gets to the inside of his backand gets
it upstairs and it finds its way down the
back of morzin and into the net one up with
Montreal Michael in the dying seconds of the
period now trying to dance his way through and
scores oh what a goal what a play by eel late
here on the first it's a little bit of Juggle
as he goes across it's a loose po through two
guys and goodas tries to play stick on Stick
that's not going to work and it's a power move
and that it's great hands in t as he goes to the
forand Here Comes forsburg now as a man in front
forsburg Ryan O'Reilly's first as a predator has
tied the game late in the second period what
a play by Philip forberg and he puts it on the
guitar strings for Ryan O'Reilly and boy oh boy
is that sweet music K oh yeah is what a tow drag
by forsberg on that one O'Reilly knows it too
gives him the point Chandler Stevenson brings
it across out back door SC the first shot on net
ends up behind brow Tick Tac Toe the bgk strike
first jaylor Stevenson comes through the neutral
zone with speed and as you mentioned tick Tap Toe
for all the youth cocky coaches out there that's
what you want to show your players that's how you
do it quick passes a quick touch Beautiful Finish
there that back door saucer pass by Brett Howen
it does not get much prettier than that KN Lander
intercepts across El with down score it's a hat
on opening night the inability of Matthews to one
time this actually hurts Allen as he just Lo the
cross thinking Matthews was going to get the quick
shot the reaction though double clutch sted around
the stick in the glove and he this game with a
minute seven wide Jonathan hubero puts the puck
behind the N to jaon L watch how hubero is going
to get this deep gets a download of man japani
and without ever waiting he recognizes that he
has linol going to the front other than that and
the Jets are too tired to react I believe that was
kapari that was his man lle but is just exhausted
and couldn't beat him to the front of the net
Martin setting up stall up Freddy St Martin puts
it in a place that a penetrating stall can receive
it with his range goes forehand backhand and then
I'm not sure consciously or not but you've got a
goal tender leading one way and you go elevation
back the other way with a beautiful elevating
backand I'm going to go consciously that is a
be here's Saad shorthanded drives to the net he
got to C up he score chis crer a shorthanded goal
fabulous efforts by zaban Jan to fight off a
check and find krider on the other side for
the short-handed goal in Str at his pass stolen
by Cole Smith right up the S charging after it
assistance he's got it he scored shorthanded goal
in Dam fashion Smith with the steel siss with the
top and look at the work there m Cole Smith just
chips that puck to the middle and siss wins the
battle here gets that net right stays on his feet
and then lifts the puck backend over Grower's
right pad in the back of the net one- nothing PRS
Sig caller huge block and Smoltz again he scores
and he's tied at l in Jersey oh baby this is sick
watch this pass by coie he wants people to come
to him he's going to get this Puck the middle of
the right there he brings everyone to a backand
to small to the back of the net watch coie come
get me boys right where they should be Nick smz
picks it up and bangs it home that is a big time
play back to broin paper off the bench C for works
his way down the wall drives to the net Faber
tried to cut to the slot Palo rebound Rosy scor
what a big goal this is too again fa he gets this
P brings it to the back hand takes it to the cage
and then the wild go to work out front Ry good
hand eye coordination on this one to get it good
hand eye coordination but how about the Battle
level for position with jordano earlier in that
play to create the chance back at the point Chan
shoot py pucking put the score teris anko's going
to get the goal but what a pass by Ridley Greg to
get him the punt watch Greg put it down RM South
between his legs and teras Seno's able to skate
into this you've got two Tampa Bay defenseman
that are reaching towards it in chac and Gan that
leaves ter sinkle wide open on the back door and
he puts it in the wide open net past Matt Tomkins
the Ottawa Senators have a one- nothing lead can
contribute pes's Drive goes wide chop shot knocked
down T by scores oh what hands this was all about
confidence he has scored three confident goals and
that one just really good swooping hands before
the goenda really good Bounce Back start for table
terrain and he's given Carolina life chck gets a
step on r where go oh a by Brady kachuck was an
Ever unbelievable play to settle this Puck down
along the wall it's a stretch pass takes it from
forehand and Spins and then it's a strong play
around radish lean in use your size your length
and your speed and then open the goal tender up
as you change your angle one more game on the
extended road trip to start cre knee lers in
to the middle drops toar scores Taris gets the end
result but how how about neander it's a great move
at the line that turns merphy around now a little
drop pass and just a perfect set up right on the
teas for tarus pass for a lefty coming across
the middle of the ice he puts it exactly where
he needed to up and over the clove between the
glove in the ear the goal tender Phillips Chris
crosses through center with Milano Sunny On The Go
Milano SRA pches a beauty score Matthew Phillips
burns the hand that used to beat him get the pot
highlight real goal for his first under the bar
and over the shoulder the goenda backand S right
there over the sliding D tanb bounces right onto
Philips stick Philips a smart guy with the pock
and he puts in his first of the year gets it back
from bunting Marty NES wraps it around they score
NES caught McKenzie Blackwood just a little off
his post on the wraparound talked about the speed
in a open here tonight about NES comes off a bench
fresh wheel rolling here down that right side this
one hits off the pad actually Blackwood made the
stop and then it hits off the inside of his left
leg and goes in off the draw Kings get it into the
corner do know centers more a chance and he scores
watch more look him look him look goes from low to
High I don't know how hard that pass was watch KS
it out the back end and he shoots it so quick once
he gets to the forehand but that first look was so
good how a player understands that you can overc
a situation and Trevor said I'm overcrowding here
let's get open he was open Kings Le by [Music] two